super tic-tac-toe begins with the usual
3x3 grid but in each of its squares
another tic-tac-toe game is placed the
first player can play in any of these 81
spaces let's say they choose to play in
the middle game in the upper right the
next player must play in the game whose
location corresponds to the square
chosen in the previous move so because X
chose the upper right Square o must play
in the upper right game
let's say o goes in the middle this
means that X must play the game in the
middle
oh because X played the middle Square o
is now forced to play in this very same
game and can block X play continues like
this until someone gets three in a row
in one of the games when they do that
entire square is marked for them if a
player is ever forced to play in a game
that has already been won well they
can't and instead they get to choose to
play Anywhere play continues until
someone wins three games that are in a
row
[Music]